c'était une journée d'audition d accuser
des parties civiles dans le procès ikea
d'anciens salariés dirigeant d'ikea
ainsi que des policiers et des
enquêteurs sont entendus dans cette
affaire d'espionnage des nouveaux
embauchés dans les années 2000
seul l'un d'entre eux a avoué admis
avoir participé à ce système de flicage
généralisé il s'agit de l'ancien
monsieur sécurité d'ikea un certain jean
françois p et c'est le seul aussi à
s'être excusé il a incriminé l'ancien
pdg a dit qu'à la france jean-louis abba
you qui aurait mis en place ce système
de recherches d'antécédents judiciaires
et ce grâce aux recherches d'une société
privée qui était a créé par jean pierre
fourré ce un ancien policier des
renseignements généraux il aurait obtenu
ses informations auprès d'un policier
ce qui est totalement illégal et ce qui
est très intéressant dans ce procès
c'est qu'il ya eu également l'audition
des parties civiles des syndicalistes
qu'ils ont expliqué avoir fait l'objet
d'un véritable harcèlement voire de
surveillance l'un d'eux explique qu'un
jour un ancien responsable lui avait dit
ah tiens tu as commis un vol à main
armée or il y à bien un homme à son nom
qui avait commis un vol vol à main armée
mais il s'agissait d'un homonyme
et donc il a été traité de braqueurs
dans cette entreprise mais cela montre
qu'il y avait des recherches à la
rencontre et je vous proposais d'
écouter adel amara
l'homme par qui tout est arrivé un
syndicaliste qui a connu beaucoup de
déboires dans cette société
on les écoute alors ce flicage s'est
cherché à ce run dans nos casiers
judiciaires stic judex mettre des des
implants au niveau des caisses au niveau
rh tout savoir sur nous quoi quand vous
avez un policier qui vous appelle sur
votre portable bio t-notes les ardents
du commissariat d'ermont qui nous
appellent sur votre portable et que vous
demandent 'est-ce que vous continuez le
syndicalisme je dis oui il m'a dit je
vous conseillerais d'arrêter conseillé
d'arrêter quoi et d' arrêter d'embêter
cas icahn n'est pas une boîte qui
discute avec les syndicats est vous qui
veut négocier avec les syndicats
il créa ce sens ce sont tout puissants
pour tout faire tout seul
des accusés et parties civiles ont
défilé à la barre aujourd'hui dans ce
procès ikea d'anciens cadres des
dirigeants handicap mais également des
policiers et des enquêteurs ont été
entendus sur cette affaire d'espionnage
des nouveaux embauchés dans les années
2000 et seul l'un d'entre eux a
véritablement avoué il s'est même excusé
il s'agit de l'ancien monsieur sécurité
a indiqué à un certain jean françois p
il a parlé d'un système de flicage
initié selon lui par l'ancien pdg d'ikea
france
jean louis baillot qui aurait demandé
donc de vérifier les antécédents
judiciaires des nouvelles recrues
il aurait pour cela fait appel à une
société privée de jean pierre fourré ce
un ancien policier des renseignements
généraux et lui aurait obtenu ces
informations par des policiers ce qui
est strictement illégal mais ce qui est
très intéressant dans ce procès c'est
que les parties civiles ont expliqué
avoir été victimes de harcèlement et
devoirs de surveillance il s'agit de
syndicaliste dit que leur vie était très
compliquée à partir de man il se sont
engagées dans l'entreprise
nous avons discuté avec un ancien
employé par lequel tout est arrivé par
lequel les relations ont été faites adel
amara également avec son avocate se rend
compte que certains syndicalistes et
notamment la figure de proue de cette
affaire par laquelle tout a commencé
adel amara a été l'objet d'une enquête
d'un rapport diligenté par la société
pour trouver les moyens de le sortir en
toute légalité
ce que la justice là l'occasion de faire
c'est de condamner avec la plus grande
fermeté les atteintes à la vie privée
des salariés et de rappeler finalement
qu' aucune activité syndicale même
jugées embarrassantes ne peut justifier
une telle atteinte à la vie privée
du côté 10 k et bien ce sont les
dénégations à l'ancien pdg jean louis
baillot mis en cause explique que les
accusations sont grotesques une
représentante d'ikea est venu expliquer
qu'un plan d'envergure avait été mis en
place pour assurer des règles de bonne
conduite et des règles d'éthique au sein
de la société et les juges devront donc
déterminer quelles sont les
responsabilités des uns et des autres
malgré les dénégations d'ikea